hello there good evening we start our
program tonight with the latest on the
situation at the associate steel plant
in mariupol the russian defense ministry
had said it reached a deal to evacuate
wounded ukrainian fighters from the
assaf style steel plant well over the
next hour we'll bring tonight's
headlines tomorrow's front pages and the
views of our paper reviewers the
political editor of the daily mirror
people and the deputy political editor
of the daily mail john stevens first
though the details of that russia
saying that a humanitarian corridor has
been opened to transport injured
ukrainian soldiers to a hospital in the
self-declared donetsk people's republic
ukraine's defense ministry has said that
264 fighters have now left the plant a
dozen buses accompanied by russian
military have been seen leaving the area
the steel works has represented the last
stronghold of ukrainian resistance in
the besieged port city and in the last
hour ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski praised the actions of those
who work to get the fighters out
thanks to the actions of the ukrainian
military the armed forces of ukraine
intelligence as well as the negotiating
team the international committee of the
red cross and the un we hope that we
will be able to save the lives of our
guys
i want to emphasize that ukraine needs
ukrainian heroes alive this is our
principle
i think that every adequate person will
understand these words